okay so that was the linear support
vector machine in the previous session
now we're going to do the non-linear
support vector machine and again
when fitting the support vector machine
the cost parameter is a tuning parameter
that one would normally have to select
we're not going to do that in these
sessions but you can use cross
validation to select that and that's
done in the in the in the r sessions in
the book but we're not going to do that
so what we're going to do here is
actually take an example from
the the more advanced textbook elements
of statistical learning which had a
canonical example of two dimension in
two dimensions where the decision
boundary was non-linear
and we're going to use the kernel
support vector machine
[Music]
to to try and
learn that boundary
and so we're going to use that example
so we can actually get the data for that
example from the elements of statistical
learning book
and you can see here
we've got a load command
and we're going to load directly from
the
url which is the web page where these
data live and so you can see the url and
the data is the mixture data it's
simulated data and so
here you see how to read data directly
from a website
okay so the data is loaded and now we
can say names and we see that this is
actually a list these data it's got a
number of components
for the for the moment the training data
are x and y
and and there's some other variables on
there which we'll get to in a moment
now first of all we've already created
an x and y for our previous example so
i'm going to just get rid of those
so that i can attach this this data this
list
which which i've now done
so let's plot the data
and there they are two-dimensional data
um
they seem to overlap quite a bit
um but we'll see that there's something
special in in the structure of these
data
we'll make a data frame with the
response y and and we'll turn that into
a factor
and
just much like before and now we'll fit
a support vector machine but here the
kernel will be radial and we'll give a
cos parameter of five and again we won't
scale the data
okay
and so that's fit
um and so now we're going to create a
grid as before and make predictions on
the grid
now these data actually came supplied
with with grid points if you look down
on the summary
the of the on the names of that one the
the list
there's two variables px1 and px2 and so
these are
a
grid of values for each of the two
variables okay so we don't actually have
to use our function that we created we
can just use expand.grid directly to
create the grid of values and so we do
that
and like before we'll predict
the the classification at each of the
values on the grid
and now we'll plot and and include the
points and color the points according to
the decision boundary
and wow look at that
so you can see the
decision boundary is non-linear now
and
and it's
the the red points are the red regions
largely to the top and the black regions
largely down below we can put
our data points in the plot and we see
where the data lies
and you can see that the the decision
boundaries to to a large extent
following where the data is but in a in
a very non-linear way
okay let's see we if we can improve this
plot a little bit further we'd actually
like to
put in a curve that gives a decision
boundary
and what we're going to do to do that is
we're going to use the contour function
okay
um
on the data on the on the
data frame is also a
variable called prob
and prob actually gives these data was
simulated and prob gives the true
probability of a plus one versus a minus
one at every value on the on the grid
that we have here
okay so we can do two things we're going
to use the contour function and we're
gonna we're gonna plot the contour of
prob at a half which would be the true
decision boundary for these data
and then what we're going to do is we're
going to
we're going to predict from our model
we're going to predict not just the
class label but we're going to predict
the function itself and we'll
we'll get the decision boundary that's
learned for these data by plotting the
contour of that function the zero quant
contour because that function we
classify to plus one if it's positive
otherwise to minus one and so we're
going to do that for each of these and
include them on the plot
okay
so
the first one is we'll just predict our
fit
on the grid
okay but we tell it decision values
equals 2 because we want to get that
function the actual function and not
just the classification
and the way it returns that it returns
it as an attribute of the actual class
of classified values so we have to pull
off that that attribute
and so we use the attributes function
that pulls off all the attributes and
then we we access the one called
decision and so now we have the the
function that we want
and
we
once again we have our grid actually
we've made it already wasn't need to
make it again
and
we um
we've got our classification again so
now we we make the same plot as we had
before
we add our points again and now we'll
make a contour
and we use a contour function and it it
requires those two grid sequences as
well
and then it wants the function you want
to contour in the form of a matrix
and if you look at the dimensions of of
px1 and px2 you'll see they're 69 and 99
and this function we're going to contour
at level 0 and we're going to add it to
the plot
and sure enough you can see that tracks
the decision boundary so that's a really
handy way of plotting a non-linear
decision boundary in in two dimensions
and finally we include the truth
which is the contour of the
probabilities which we're gonna that's
the
0.5 contour
which would be the decision boundary in
terms of the the probabilities and so
that's the true decision boundary or the
what's called the bayes decision
boundary
so that's the ultimate one if we had
large amounts of data we'd hope to be
able to get very close to that but you
can see our non-linear support vector
machine has got pretty close to that
especially in the regions where we've
got data
and and so here we've seen how to
include these non-linear boundaries in
the plots
okay so we've finished the session so
once again we were using r markdown and
we've where we've mixed
actual text with our r commands
the whole the two sessions on svm i like
that and at the end of it all we can use
the function knit
and
it runs through all the code and
produces a nice web document that
summarizes
all that we've done this is something
you can share with your colleagues
um you can display it you can put it on
your own website
puts all the figures in
and you know and and shows exactly what
you've done and all the plots everything
that we produced in somewhat
nice quality as well and so this this is
a document that you can save and and
distribute